just how tight are some of these races
and does the political climate favor
Republicans well Mark everything we've
seen really over the last couple weeks
shows that the political climate is
definitely favoring Republicans that
said extremely close that's where these
races are right now you've got more than
a half dozen Senate seats Senate races
right now that are within the margin of
error in the polling you'll have an
outlier here or there but what that
underscores Mark is that in races around
the country there hasn't been any break
towards a big Republican wave candidates
have haven't really had the ability to
separate themselves over the last couple
weeks and so we're really going into
election night as Republicans eye those
six seats needed for a majority not
really knowing how close they're going
to get to it or the possibility that
they might go way over it it's it's
there's a lot up in the air mark Lisa
speaking of up in the air talk to us
about the election night math what's
that look like so Republicans as Phil
pointed out need to win six seats
tonight or tomorrow night three of them
are pretty much already in the bag
that's South Dakota Montana and West
Virginia so that leaves them need to win
three more from a pool of about seven so
there's just a lot more Pathways for
them to get to 51 seats than there are
you know and Democrats are really on
defense they just have more ways to get
there but you know they're feeling
confident but not all that confident in
part that's because very few strategists
on either side think that we'll have an
answer election night this this this
control the Senate this is something
that could go on well into the rest of
the week there could be a even into you
know next year there could be a runoff
in Louisiana which won't happen until
December a runoff in Georgia would be in
January and don't even get me started on
Alaska where polls don't close until
1:00 a.m. absolutely and you have to get
ballots from tribal Villages above the
Arctic Circle so this is we could see
these results could be outstanding for
quite some time wow Phil have Democrats
been running away from President Obama
in fear of being linked to the
administration and its policies yeah
absolutely mark look you haven't seen
the president on the campaign Trail for
Senate candidates he's was on the trail
for one in Michigan a race that has
pretty much moved into the safe category
for Democrats up to this point Democrats
have had a very difficult time
throughout this election cycle trying to
walk the line on the policy side of
things they mostly support what the
Obama Administration has done but the
political climate is so negative for
this Administration that candidates have
had no other option than to try and
distance themselves I think what you're
going to see over these last couple days
Republicans over and over again
hammering that President Barack Obama is
on the ballot and Democrats trying
desperately to get away from that Lisa
if as Kentucky Republican senator ran
Paul has said this election is a
referendum on the president will Mr
Obama and Congressional Democrats get
credit for the economy are they going to
get credit for an unemployment rate that
is now below 6% and will he get credit
for growth that we just learned last
week it has been above 3% for four out
of the past five quarters well Mark
you're right the unemployment rate is
below 6% but people don't vote on
abstract numbers right voters vote on
how they feel the wages have been
stagnant part of why that unemployment
rate has dropped uh all our economic
analysis shows is because as people have
stopped looking for work so in terms of
how voters are experiencing their daily
economic lives they're not feeling all
that positive yet and they're still
feeling awfully anxious and that anxiety
is what Democrats are worried that
they're bringing with them to the polls
so that means I I I guess in a sense
then that they're looking I used this in
the past but it seems Germaine now that
President Obama's almost like Kryptonite
to these folks they just Mr President
we'll stick with our local issues so you
are not as Phil suggested some
Republicans are saying on the ballot
with us that's exactly right as Phil
pointed out Republicans are trying to
nationalize this race Democrats are
doing their their hardest to try to make
it about local issues in North Carolina
that's State education funding in
Arkansas that's the farm bill and you
can see that by where President Obama
has traveled Democrats and contested
states don't want him they want former
President Bill Clinton and Hillary
Clinton they're saying you know
President Obama stick to these blue
States stick to these Governor's races
please please don't come to Arkansas or
Alaska or Kentucky wow that's a damning
indictment Phil the results how are they
going to be greeted by Wall Street if
Republicans win control of the Senate
thereby setting the agenda for President
Obama's last two years in office well
based on where their campaign money has
been going over the last two years the
Republican Senate is what uh Wall Street
is looking for the money has started to
head into that Direction look you talked
to financial services lobbyists and town
you talk to some Wall Street Executives
who are kind of involved in the
political sphere they look forward to
the possibility of having a chamber uh
run or Chambers run by Republicans on
Capitol Hill there's a possibility that
on Dodd Frank they could get some
changes they want there's a possibility
just that there's an into to gridlock at
least on Capitol Hill I think large
scheme of things though Mark everybody
on Wall Street is keenly aware 2016 is
the election that really matters 2014 is
just setting the tone and laying the
groundwork for the results that will
lead to this next campaign so us
tomorrow's the appetiz of the entree is
yet to come Mark Mark we might as well
have already started
2016 no joke